So we're going to look at
an example of a relation or
a table that we just talked about.
This example that we have here
is- the name of this relation or
table is Employee because it store
Information about employees that we
have, maybe in a certain company.
So, the columns or
the attributes schema that we're
talking about is defined as follows.
You're going to have an employee name,
going to have an identifier for
the department in which they work,
that's Did,
the salary we don't have the value,
but we have a code for the salary.
We have the employee's ID and
then we have their phone.
The information about a given employee
consists of their name, the department,
the salary code, their ID, and their
phone numbers, so you can reach them.
Now, in this particular organization,
we have a bunch of employees.
Robin, Neil, Jasmine,
Cody, Holly, and so on.
So for each of them we're
going to have a tuple.
So if you look at sort of
a given row in this table here,
that is what we are calling a tuple.
And we uniquely identify
those by the employee ID.
So in case of Robin for
example 2345 is the primary
key value for employee Robin.
So we are going to see primary keys
are how we actually say what set of
employees.
You may want to get
information about them.
Things like that.
So this is the key, and these
are the key values that we have here.
So as you can see,
for each employee that information
makes up a tuple in the table.
The collection of those
instructed organize this way.
That's what makes a table.
The various attributes that
we have which define what's
stored in this table is based on
this schema that we have here.
I have something else here
which a foreign key and
the reason I included that
here is because sometimes
you may want to do operations
across different tables.
So foreign key basically is going
to be key in some other table,
and we can do what is called joins for
example.
Put data together from multiple tables.
Well you can say,
this is the foreign key that should
match a primary key in another table.
And then I want to pull information
about Robin's department salary code and
employee ID from here and
her Social Security, address,
other things from different table and
things like that.
So there maybe the department IDs that
keep for example and won't be unique
if you're trying to pull Social Security
numbers and things like that.
So foreign key is essentially a primary
key somewhere else and somehow,
sometimes you may have to sort of
combine information from multiple tables
and we use these keys for doing that.
And so some of the fields may be
the attribute values that we have here.
You're not going to use them as the key
for accessing Tuples from here, but
when you referred another relation and
operation across multiple tables,
that's where they get used.
Again, if you've done
your database scores,
you probably have learnt a lot more
about it than what we need here.